So now that we have seen an example of loop unrolling let's do a loop and
rolling quiz. let's say we have the following loop. We load something from
memory. We add it to some sort of a sum in R3, and then we move our
memory pointer by four bytes and then if we have reached some end of an array,
then we exit otherwise we loop back. So what this loop is really doing is
it's summing up an array. Let's say we have a processor that is in order and
executes one instruction per cycle. A load takes three cycles. So, for
example here, because we are using the result of the load,
there would be 2 stall cycles in between and ADD or ADDI, take 2 cycles each.
So for example, between the ADDI and the branch, there would be 1 stall cycle.
So the question for you is after scheduling this loop,
but without applying any unrolling, it takes how many cycles to
do 1000 iterations of the loop? And then after unrolling once,
meaning we do the work of two of these iterations per new iteration, and
then scheduling the loop, it takes how many cycles for 1000 iterations?